what's going on reject nation we are
going to watch today the falcon and the
winter soldier
very excited to check this out marvel if
you haven't done so already make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell and also go ahead hit that like
button helps get this video seen
we also did an interview with carrie
skoglund that you guys can go ahead and
check out
i think i enjoyed it more than anyone
else in that room of course dude gotta
mention you guys probably heard me make
this spiel before this is reaction
highlights
obviously can't show the whole show
full-length reaction watch along so
you're single with a time coder over at
our patreon
major thanks to everyone who has shown
their support by following us over there
we cover so many shows we're at the same
tier you get the option for highlights
and watch along
included lastly gotta thank eric over at
nurikronic
for editing this for us you're a good
dude a sexy dude
let's smack that ass all right guys
let's go
i forgot to mention this in the intro
originally without giving like a whole
big spiel about it just wanted to give
you a heads up that uh yes this one is
going up on friday and
like all the one divisions went up on
friday as well moving forward
they'll probably be going up on saturday
morning so you'll have to wait just a
day longer but you know watch everyone
else's and then
come back to ours on saturday mornings
and then we'll
do our best to get the finale up on
friday hope you guys understand
don't worry the reactions will still be
delivered to you guys in a probably a
more quality manner
with this scheduling thank you
i wonder if he has to like turn it in oh
god that would be
painful almost
he's gonna have to learn to feel like
he's earned it
that he deserves it plane has already
entered tunisian airspace
and sam this has to be subtle
subtle got it
we'll see about that
yo you're way too comfortable doing that
oh no
[Music]
it's too much twilight zone for you
i felt realistic yeah i am
ah that's badass
let's get you out of here yeah i know
that's i think that's the dude who has
done all the kickity kicks with
the beginning of the boat heist yeah
oh here we go wow real stumbling
[Music]
here we go
this is crazy
[Music]
god the use of povs man
oh my god oh my god
he's just one man one foul can
you red wing
[Music]
if we get to the border he's not gonna
follow
what's up
to get to the border he's not gonna
follow
because of jurisdiction or something so
he's playing in two oh he might
okay i feel like that's a clue to plot
development
i can't believe this is the day after
everyone came back from the snap
everyone's right back
whoa whoa man
oh
oh my god this is so cool
[Music]
i hope that guy doesn't die oh bam right
there
they call themselves the flag smashers
flag smash bag smashers
basically they think that the world is
better during the blip
trust me if anything gets serious you
let me know i do got to ask you though
because like online there's just been a
lot of
crazy crazy conspiracy theories some
people they think that
he's in a secret base on the moon
looking down over so are you off to
washington what are you doing there
moonstone
steve represented the best in all of us
courageous righteous and he mastered
posing
stoically
symbols
are nothing without the women and men
that give them meaning
and this thing i don't know if there's
ever been a greater symbol
but it's more about the man who propped
it up
and he's gone thank you captain america
but this belongs to you
[Applause]
what oh he's like you volunteered it
over
he's gonna have to steal it back you
have to kill it at some point man it's
gonna be a cool heist sequence you have
to steal
[Music]
[Music]
hell hydro
[Music]
wow he really was that ruthless
so mr barnes are you still having
nightmares
james i asked you a question are you
still having nightmares
oh come on really you gonna do the
notebook thing
why passive aggressive you don't talk
all right
i crossed the name off the list of my
events yesterday
senator atwood
she was a hydropon for years so rule
number one
you can't do anything illegal
tomorrow never does yeah
what was rule number two nobody gets
hurt it's a big one and why isn't it
rule number one
and what about rule number three oh he's
so bad i completed rule number three
i am no longer the winner soldier i'm
james bucky barnes and you're
part of my efforts to make amends
didn't help with the nightmares well
like i said i didn't have any
i think i saw zemo's name on the list
you're going to have to open
up and understand that some people
really do
want to help you and that they can be
trusted i trust
people like like like like sam
i had a little
calm in wakanda
and other than that i just went from one
fight to another
for 90 years so
now that you've stopped fighting what do
you want
to get back to fighting you've got your
mind back
you are being pardoned i mean these are
good
things you're free
to do what
be a lyft driver hey you know we're good
with cars you guys didn't order the
usual huh
killing off our adventures you should
ask grout
no she's mephisto you don't want to do
this no i'm really sorry about him
why are you sorry okay
oh i have a shift but if you want to
come back here i should be done around
10.
she is spy oh yeah she is sharon carter
he was killed the police said
wrong place wrong time but
i will never know what really happened
to you
the guy you shot earlier oh
god i hope not uncle sam
what's up that's right
what's more american than uncle sam you
gotta marvel at it
marvel every day i'm making five and
spending ten so why don't you let me
help you no
don't start with that you're out there i
do things my way here you
should have sold the shield you can
have a hundred bucks i'll set the
appointment
i won't let you down we can turn this
[ __ ] around
to the rescue huh always
well let's get some dinner
let's eat some shrimp have you had any
shrimp today
but a red snapper some tilapia
i hope you do not have a ptsd freak out
in the middle of your date
he's gonna be fine yeah he'll just might
shoot her once yeah
yeah i have a reflex to pin her down
right now it'll be a
crusher skull let's play a game yeah you
like games
love them keep a couple games around for
boring chefs
we'll grab a couple beers this one's war
related
[Laughter]
what are you doing i'm reading your mind
please don't is this an honor professor
x
no no she's a next man i think it's
really sweet you're spending time with
yuri
no there's no word for someone whose
kids die
excuse me are you good
i'm just gonna leave and not come back
hey
what are you doing here
all right it's him yeah god i hold you
for lunch
[Music]
i don't think you need to tell him
[Music]
i mean he deserves to know what happened
to his son but
same time you know you could just
explain the circumstances and not the
part where it was
you yeah that went down well with toni
[Laughter]
martin
oh is that the actual flag smasher group
yeah oh okay yeah
homeboy infiltrated this pretty easily
yo
[Applause]
so i don't know how jurisdiction works
here but i don't have to place you under
arrest
oh hell no no no no i mean i thought he
might die but
not like this oh
no i never see these characters in these
superhero properties get loans
it's relatable i don't know do you i
do yeah
i always wanted to be an adventurer oh
man it's a dream come true you know
getting a loan
and we're gonna deny that loan you have
no income over the last five years
how can you have income if you don't
exist sarah
uh oh my god i've been
gone sure but these days with everyone
just
showing up well things tightened up holy
[ __ ] is there any chance and of course
you could say no that i could get a
selfie with your arms out are you
serious
i love that reaction from her i'm truly
sorry
it's weird how the blip seems to semi
reflect the pandemic of today yeah
put a hashtag
in an insurrection god face smash my
flag smash
[Laughter]
wait you don't think he could be uh i'll
circle back to you
oh my god sam you better look at this
what about all the people that saw him
saw that stupid super strength [ __ ]
while we love heroes who put their lives
on the line to defend earth
we also need a hero to defend this oh
crap it's happening
we need a real person no who embodies
america
no no
no join me in welcoming
your new captain america
no wow that really stings
damn absolutely oh it's not his either
oh that really stings you feel it
it's right here oh that
is messed up
[Laughter]
oh that like really hurt absolutely you
know if you've been following the
coverage of
this show and trailers are like yeah
it's supposed to happen at some point
but the way it was executed and played
out like oh yeah
you know sam was doing the right thing
he turned in the shield he was feeling
worthy of it but this is like messed up
to turn around and give it out like
yeah yeah exactly that was such a slap
the whole point was it belongs to steve
you know yeah no it just belongs to this
other white brother is this other guy
who can look like captain america
yeah dr strange and mephista ah they're
both coming to episode two
the multiverse is here okay
ponytail done let's talk about falcon
and winter soldier
you know this interesting tone that the
show has
that seems to be about self-worth
yeah yeah like you're watching it and
you have
falcon no sam who's dealing with the
emotions
of cap gave him the shield and then to
go off that ending of end games it's
like oh damn you're gonna bury than that
captain america
you know so you think it's headed and
then here yeah
cap's gone and how do you deal with the
weight of that how do you deal with the
pressure
i mean i don't blame the guy for feeling
unworthy
of that it's like even with everything
we've seen sam have to do and go through
in these movies it's never been to the
extent
that captain america has had to do all
that craziness over the course of many
decades yeah
in the arrows you know beyond that
though it's like just to live up to that
image
that's rough you know so him feeling
unworthy in that area and then you got
bucky who's just really struggling with
a sense of identity you know like
cap was the one guy steve rogers who he
could lean on
and the one remnant from his actual home
time and place
yeah steve rogers was the one guy he
could he could count on
you know they had this little detail
here of sam was has been trying to get
in touch with bucky you know just i
think to like reach out or connect to
him
i can't hold the responsibility of
holding that shield but i can hold on to
the responsibility of looking after this
being your
best friend i'll try my best to be this
guy's friend both of
us second bananas gotta come together my
friend why don't you text me back
well they're both dealing with having
like the world has to deal with not
having like iron man and captain america
and then also
dealing with the post blip events but
mainly for these two
they have so much of being within
captain america's shadow to such a big
big degree you know i feel like by this
point bucky would have been killed or
been in jail
if it wasn't for captain america right
or at best he'd still be for hydra or
something you know and the path that sam
has gone down is all inspired by captain
america so
for them he was the main guy they looked
up to
and now to have to be without him and
you're seeing the past of what their
personal lives are like i find so
interesting it started off with this
like really
great action scene like that action
scene is easily the best falcon action
hands down ever put on screen
already the first 15 minutes of the show
best falcon action we've ever gotten it
was really well choreographed and
stylized and
this director i know i mentioned the
interview at the top of
of of this video but the truth is we're
shooting this on a thursday
and then we're interviewing her tomorrow
yes but the interview should be up
before
this video is up so that's what's going
on in real time for you guys right
first i think it's so great how her
direction has such a great grip on
not just the action scenes but the
pacing
and capturing the perspectives of when
you're cutting
like it's shot differently when you're
with bucky than when you are with sam
especially when you look at like that
therapy scene you're capturing that all
from the way how
bucky is experiencing this but also
she's got a great grip on the action you
know like dealing with the povs and
talking about perspective
even with the action scenes like i love
that going into the povs
yeah at all of it like the pacing and
the mood the editing of all this is so
well calculated it feels more akin to
winter soldier than any of the other
marvel movies
but it doesn't feel like it's trying to
be winter soldier you know
well no because i feel like if that was
the case it would be trying to crunch
bones like every five minutes
yeah i thought this really did nicely to
have the really awesome action because
too the winter soldier flashback
sequence was
harrowing as well but then to balance
that out with these very intimate and
contemplative tones and i love like the
contrast where yeah you look at that
therapy scene it's all
close and gauzy and then you look at
like the exchange between
roadie and sam which is very wide and
you're sort of looking at them from afar
through all these memories of someone
that they both lost but especially sam
lost and whatnot and so in the visual
language like there's a whole lot of
character being expressed along with all
the
really fun and easy to pick out yeah
yeah
i think it's all wonderfully on display
and i love that we're getting different
layers then like the trailers will pitch
you on the action the banter
the fun right the things you'd kind of
expect of something i felt like a little
bit more buddy caught but this is
like a deliberate slow paced drama
it wasn't intense necessarily this
episode it's all character set up like
it's an exciting action scene at the top
where you do get the return of leaper
what's his name bartok
the truck he has a standout scene in
winter soldier
one of the fights and he ties into
thunder but like if i'm not remember we
learned not long ago that he remember or
something that yeah that character ties
into
uh thunderbolts and with zemo coming up
that makes all the more sense too
we're not gonna spend too much time
figurizing on these videos
considering what happened
yeah mephisto look over though we'll
cover those videos
i'm just gonna be here to review the
episode right now
you get this exciting action scene but
really this is more on tune with like an
amc drama show
people say one of his like that's a slow
burner i'm like no it's not
that's slow oh god the slow burn is just
waiting to find out what's going on
by comparison maybe yeah but it's not a
slow burner this is sad this is
like this this is a slow burn this right
here is a slow burner they don't even
meet up in this episode yeah yeah which
i also love which you know i'm excited
to now
see when they finally get together and
how they both
pursue honoring the cat mantle because
too this sets up a great arc i think for
sam
in terms of the real motivation to take
the mantle you know i
loved all that personal character stuff
we got with him he
is adored as a being an avenger
being a hero like he's praised and when
he's with his
i think latino friend
i forget his name that's danny ramirez
yeah yeah yeah
when you're with him in that country
when they have that scene when he tells
them about the flag smashers even there
he's receiving praise i thank you for
bringing back my wife to me that one
citizen there says and then they go to
get the loan even the bank guy is like
yo you're a freaking avenger they're
gonna take photos with you and he's
trying to
you know play into it uh to try to help
get the loan
but even then i love the questions that
it explores of how do you guys make
money and they don't make a joke out
like
there's there's something that feels
light in time and humor a little
humorous about it but
i don't feel like they're making fun of
it in a way they're actually addressing
like a real concern
yeah you know like he could still be
broke he can still have a hard time
making ends meet he's talking about it's
all just a lot of good will like it
really
they don't get paid to do this thing
unless it is like certain government
jobs or missions or something where he
can earn a living because he is you know
he's part of the air force
even with the clout there then you're
getting the information about what it's
like post
blip and how oh yeah since post blip
been overwhelmed i've been overwhelmed
so the laws on all this has to change
you know like oh you don't have any
income we haven't been dead for five
years you know like that's
so fascinating and feels like that's
what the world would do hey you know
yeah man like the second like the world
readjust a smaller amount of people and
then from there it's like well i'm sorry
if you're not like the perfect candidate
we're not gonna approve you
still it's crazy yeah and so i like
going back to his family home
life you know wilson family seafood how
he wants to keep that intact the
relationship with his sister he's going
back to his roots you know
and in a way that we're still able to
discover the back story more of who sam
is you know like he joined the air force
he had a former partner named i wanted
to say riley
my wingman ryan who i'm i'm wondering if
we're gonna get flashbacks with this
riley character
after mentioning him in winter soldier
so we know some of the stuff but getting
to see his whole backstory here we're
gonna
dive into his family life in louisiana
makes you just that much more connected
to a character like this and then
meanwhile in the big government world
they're abusing the whole captain
america image and then with bucky
you know hiro turned villain turned hero
and he has to deal with being a like
he's really trying
what i found interesting is he's really
trying to just make it on his own and be
a good guy
and just actually have a sort of life
maybe he's not like
really trying to be a good guy but you
know like he's at least
trying to balance his own ledger at
least he's making
amends by still being a vigilante along
the way he's doing it the best way he
knows how
because yeah that notebook i think i saw
zemo's name i'm sure there's some like
fun little nuggets and easter eggs in
that moment where you do see
everything in that notebook but i love
both their performances like i feel more
connected to them now than
ever before i've more been charmed by
them and i've i've
cared about bucky but what i loved is
that here
bucky had a lot of personality in
captain america the first avenger
then he's like super duper stoic and
winter soldier
and then in civil war you get some
shades in certain moments of some of
that nostalgic personality but you know
i'm just giving the situation more of a
serious guy and then here
you're like okay now we he he got
another redefine of his personality he's
got some
real charm he's got the repressed
sarcastic [ __ ] thing going on about
it you know yeah
but in a way they're both putting on a
front you know
like sam's having a really difficult
time with the waiting with him talking
about how
you know i thought that the show belongs
to someone else i realized that someone
else is captain america
at the same time if you really had that
much faith in captain america and
captain america chose
you and you were going against captain
america's
wishes paradox have you heard of this
ship of thesis
neither is the true successor both are
the true successor
and then bucky and sam will both have a
shield yeah they'll be perfect
one will fly off we won't know where he
went and there you go just keep
replacing it around the strap
but for him to honor him that much but
at the end of the day you're going
against what
his last wishes were of the last time
you spoke with him which was for you to
have that responsibility so in a way
you're going against captain america and
i'm not fault
and i'm saying that i imagine that
probably weighs on him to a certain
extent
of the fact that he's going against his
final wishes so that's what i mean i
think if you get all this rich character
nuance just in a lot of more of the
subtlety of their body language and
facial expressions
there's a lot of great quiet moments
here yeah absolutely which is like the
stuff that you don't get to have with
these characters in the movies which is
what i've been loving the most about the
shows is that you can really then expand
upon these people who we care about
mostly because of their relationship to
steve
and now we can care about them for their
whole backstory
lives and whatnot and that's i think the
benefit of the tv show treatment
yeah because you really get that
especially with the old chinese guy
you know like yuri i think i think you
see it a lot with um
anthony mackey uh but i think the camera
lingers a little bit longer on
sebastian stan when it comes to his
scenes just because of the nature of who
his character is
yeah whereas like anthony mack sam like
tends to be always super charming and
super fun like yeah that's the thing
but when you see when he's not doing
that you could see a lot of more in that
somber
side in him where his bucky's kind of
always got that going for him
yeah yeah that's like the veneer of sam
is the upbeat hero guy and then the
veneer of bucky is just like
calm and collected when really there's a
storm underneath
yes yeah you really get that sense of
his performance so i feel like they've
already
in the first episode have exceptionally
elevated these characters
absolutely i already love them i know
they were great yeah they were cool
characters
and i love that we love them on their
own yeah yeah before they even
it's a good point that's a good point
that's a really awesome scene with him
and rhodey as well because i'm sure a
lot of
maybe not to the same caliber but i
imagine there's a similar feeling of
identity that
rhodey probably has with sam given this
moment we know they're going to
eventually go down some big mission it's
going to be a cool spy movie
over the course of this mini series but
what i really liked is really settling
into the fact that they're trying to
have personal lives
post-split you know like bucky's trying
to go out on dates but he gets triggered
way too easily i love the scene with his
therapist
i love the therapist portrayal because
it's different it's refreshing
yeah i don't imagine real nervous behave
this way
just i mean maybe there are maybe that's
just the approach and style she has
chosen to take with someone like bucky
but i love that she's kind of like fed
up with him already and he's impatient
with a guy who requires the most
patience yeah yeah
well even that just extra piece of
context of her being like look i was in
the military i've seen
silly shades of what you've seen like it
even that added a little
extra piece of flesh to the context that
i feel like you might not have gotten
before
i mean she's really blunt what i love
about that approach is i generally don't
care for the way how therapists are
portrayed in movies and shows
don't tell me how you feel let me give
you the most generic google
first advice that the screenwriter
looked at the impression of a therapist
by someone who hasn't been to one yeah
so yeah
i thought that her character was uh
really really good i'm looking forward
to more scenes with them
and you know you got like of course the
cool plot setups the flag smashers
i love that concept of yes and they'd
like the blip better you know
unified without borders because there
was that emphasis on borders in that
first action scene
but that was mainly about you crossed
that border you're out of jurisdiction
kind of
there's going to be even more trouble
now yeah yeah yeah but there's a very
specific thing with the flag smashers of
yeah
wanting unity by thinking like flags you
know take taking those down out of the
equation it helps unify
the world instead of dividing us they
actually create a divide by doing this
but i don't know it seems like there's
some real evil [ __ ] they're up to as
well
yeah the thing is like i hope that that
becomes you know an interesting nuanced
storyline because on the one hand there
are aspects of that ideology that are
appealing especially while living in the
blip
yeah yeah yeah and then to see it
although here we go down in switzerland
it looks like a pretty violence we're
robbing ramps
yeah but unity but also we're gonna rob
money and we're gonna
smash this guy's family now i'm gonna
stop on your head you know as a peace
liberation are we maybe not so peaceful
but
yeah i do hope that gets maybe a little
more nuanced but it's a great setup for
the ideology of the show and the mantle
of captain
america who's tied to a boundary
you know and i love that this world
seems really
imbued in a post-blip world
that just seems to be such a looming
feeling
throughout this from beginning to end
they've done a good job of just making
that part of the atmosphere for
for everything post i mean yeah i mean
in one division it's not really
because one division is so specific yeah
it's westview you're in wanda's mind and
worlds
specifically for most of it whereas here
you're you're really hopping around the
world
yeah washington louisiana it looks like
new york switzerland so
you're hopping around but no matter
where you go the blip has occurred and
now we're really dealing with
more than just yay people are back but
also the negative consequences of
what it's like to just try to adjust to
this system and how the financial world
treats you and the abuse of power i
think the show is going to get pretty
political with this commentary
yeah absolutely because too i mean even
in that scene with them and the
loan i was sitting there going well yes
i understand that there are all these
blip
consequences and what not to keep in
mind but also
you know i wonder what this would have
looked like if bucky came in for a loan
you know yeah that's true i feel like
there is a lot of realism to peel back
i also really love the performance of
sam's sister yeah i thought she was
great she had so much
great presence and like just history in
her performance like
she's so great at pulling those like
exhausted kind of throwing away a line
but not
kind of things yeah i love that nuanced
layer of
for sam you know he was gone but it felt
like a few dates that passed but for her
you feel that weight of
she's had to deal with the loss of
people for five years and now that
you're back
you gotta understand i'm a different
person you know yeah i haven't had this
boat along with me for so long i can't
do it any longer
i love that like extra detail of
psychology with these characters
the people who have to adjust to a new
life after being gone and the people
have to adjust the fact that people are
back
and after having dealt with such heavy
loss and pain for five years how do you
just adjust
it's not returning to old it's
essentially a new reality at this point
people have talked about it'd be cool to
see a world that's like a show that
takes place within the blip but i think
exploring the emotions
of what it's like for people is
sufficient enough
yeah i feel like kind of dealing with
the aftermath of everyone getting back
kind of makes it richer because you
still have all the people who did
survive dealing with that but then you
have the added complication of yeah
everyone who's back and it was like
hey it's great to be alive oh things are
in
disrepair i love that detail of the flag
smashers preferring the world when there
was a blip
and like it actually makes it more
personal now automatically yeah are we
gonna try and re-blip the world how are
we
gonna proceed with this like how super
and crazy in scope is their plan gonna
become they set them both up for great
character arcs
you know bucky's especially a little bit
more on the nose as soon as you get a
therapy scene you'd be more overt about
it when you got a therapy scene
tell me the subtext yeah it's a
psychology scene you're gonna get more
blood stuff coming out yeah he's a guy's
very lonely has to make amends
with not just the people of his past but
you know with his own inner demons
himself make amends with himself learn
like a like i said this deals a lot of
self-worth
but then i think like the relationship
that he will form with sam will be more
meaningful than just fun buddy
i think it's going to lead down
something where it's very meaningful
that they have this bond with each other
oh yeah they're going to be tied
together by you know like
guiding the principles of steve that
they both shared like the qualities that
made them both
like right hand men for him are probably
gonna kind of join them together
yeah yeah i mean some quick fun things
seeing this smithsonian sure there's
gonna be a lot of great easter eggs in
there they got their
their money's worth at all those sets
yeah captain america's presence is
another thing that really
looms over this show these are very dark
souls without captain america
uh around to help guide them which i
think is neat bucky date
talks about tiger photos what was up
with the tigers and wanda vision you
know what i'm saying
bucky recalls his siblings and one of
them's alive there's like 48 of them you
said right
yeah maybe we'll get an episode where he
goes and visits somebody in a restaurant
gotta be at least
one there's gotta be yeah i'm just
trying to think you know there's still
people hanging on
this is a few years in the future though
so maybe they've all died off by now
yeah i hope this asian lady who bucky
went on a date with he will get to have
a good day with her one day but i feel
like it's all gonna end tragically
and he's gonna tell that guy what he did
and he won't forgive bucky
because sometimes you can't expect
forgiveness from others but you have to
still learn to forgive yourself
regardless
that is a big lesson i think [ __ ] he's
gonna struggle with that also
yeah i think i need to apply that lesson
i do too we all need to appreciate
you don't deserve forgive me i don't i
know i'm a bad you're a suffer
i am gonna cut i'm gonna go find some
more suffering because this isn't enough
suffering is waiting for you and you
deserve it anyway guys
hey falcon and winter soldier what'd you
think of this
did you love it huh are you like this is
stupid marvel should release everything
all at once
did they learn their lesson from what
happened with one division it'd be in my
mind when
bananas are trying to figure it out and
i play marvel for that
they learn their lesson from when the
anticipation cycle worked
too well maybe they could knock that off
so i can forget about this by the
weekend
yeah damn you characters one action
uh all right guys leave your thoughts
down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
mirage i nominate you i nominate you
if this winter soldier and this
falcon had to spread his wings across an
adventure and we needed a third party to
help us
out we're calling you niraj you're the
one who'd be like man
it's boring on this road trip we gotta
take or flight
what do we do narage play some tunes
niraj would know what to do
always sending over some poppetunes or
if we were like
wow the chittari have invaded the east
coast again
where do we go to learn our way around
the city will you know those in these
coasts
[Music]
he's onto the east coast or like hey
what obscure
movie reference did they drop in this
one piece of witty banter
niraj knows which movie reference
they're making because he's seen every
movie practically
who's making the witty banter no one yet
in this episode
we we would be making the witty banter
so the idea is we're made in the witty
banter and narash has to
tell us what the banter is right that
one needs a second draft
thank you for being here naraj